hey everybody this is gonna be really
quick
tomorrow's livestream which will go up
at its usual time 7:00 p.m. Eastern is
going to be a fundraiser and all
proceeds from that live stream are going
to go towards the black visions
collective which is a Minnesota based
group pursuing racial justice and
equality you shouldn't need me to tell
you why I'm doing this
and you definitely should not be
listening to me for an opinion on
everything that's going on so I'm not
gonna do that I'm letting you know now
so that as many of you as are interested
in helping out will be there the live
stream will not be me giving my opinions
on everything going on or a lecture
about it it will be something a bit more
in my wheelhouse there will be
opportunities for you to donate in in in
ways that fit what I tend to do but that
is what the money will be going towards
so if you would like to spread word
about this I would like to get a good
turnout and see what we can do with this
thank you stay safe be well